By the time a movie hits your screen,
every frame has been examined by dozens,
if not hundreds, of eyes. Still,
anachronisms and magical color
changing shirts do make their way in to
films. Here are some of our favorites.
Judging by its 16 screen adaptations, Pride and
Prejudice is arguably Jane Austen's most beloved
work. It's an archetypal rom-com about
the cross-class romance between proper
Mr. Darcy and fiercely independent Elizabeth
Bennet. Keira Knightley received an Academy
Award nomination for playing Elizabeth in the
2005 incarnation. Director Joe Wright set his
take on Pride and Prejudice in 1797, around the
time Austen started work on the original novel.
The movie strives for historical authenticity, but
fell short in the footwear department. Elizabeth
is seen traipsing around a garden in rubber boots,
or Wellingtons as they're called in the U.K. But
Wellies weren't a thing in Britain until the
1850s making Elizabeth's boots an anachronism.
Former teen journalist Cameron Crowe
won a screenwriting Oscar for his
semi-autobiographical movie Almost Famous.
Patrick Fugit plays 15-year-old William Miller,
a precociously talented music writer hired
to review a Black Sabbath concert. Backstage,
he meets the members of Stillwater, the fictional
band he tours with for the rest of the movie. At
one point, William watches the band members argue
about the design of their first-ever t-shirt.
"Gentlemen, your first t-shirts have arrived."
Then, later in the film, Stillwater makes a
stop in Kansas where the lead singer takes
William to a house party. There's a fan of
the band there, wearing a Stillwater T-shirt,
and it's not the design the musicians were
discussing earlier, for its first and only shirt.
Between 1973's American Graffiti, the 1974
debut of Happy Days, and 1978's Grease,
the 1970s were full of nostalgia for the
1950s. Grease was an absolute blockbuster,
becoming the highest-grossing film of the
year. But despite all the poodle skirts,
malt shops, and slicked-back hair,
it was very much a 70s film, and a
touch of the contemporary showed
in some of the costume choices.
During a pivotal dance scene, Danny Zuko, played
by John Travolta, wears some quintessentially
1970s threads that no teenager would or could
have worn in the 1950s — namely a big-collared
pink dress shirt under a leisure suit. A few
moments later, at the climax of "Born to Hand
Jive," Marty Maraschino, played by Dinah Manoff,
slides across the floor, exposing an accessory
worn to protect the actor which was not a
fashion choice for the character: a kneepad.
Unforgiven, winner of the 1992 Academy
Award for Best Picture, is one of the
bleakest Westerns ever made. It offers a gritty,
unsettling look at life in the West in the 1880s,
in contrast to most mid-20th century Westerns
with their clear heroes and villains and rosy,
adventurous spirit. In Unforgiven, former
criminal William Munny, played by Clint Eastwood,
descends on a tiny Wyoming town in search of two
violent cowboys with a bounty on their heads,
much to the chagrin of anti-vigilante
sheriff Little Bill Daggett. Daggett
holds his pants up with a belt threaded
through sewn-on belt loops. Pants with
built-in belt loops were available before
the 20th century, but were very rare.
The Levi Strauss Company didn't begin
attaching belt loops until the 1920s.
In the late 19th century, when Unforgiven is
set, cowboys and other denizens of the American
west wore suspenders. Or else they wore pants
that fit tightly enough that they stayed put.
In the Godfather films, Francis Ford Coppola
tells an epic tale about the Corleones,
a Sicilian-American family who figures large
in the organized criminal underworld of the
early to mid-20th century. The first Godfather is
set primarily in the 1940s, and filmmakers paid a
lot of attention to authenticity, capturing the
look and clothing of World War II-era America.
But it's not easy to shoot on the streets,
and mistakes happen. In one sequence,
a vintage car pulls up to a 1940s-looking
Las Vegas hotel. In the background stand
a couple of onlookers — not actors.
They're the very picture of late '60s
to early '70s middle-class America,
down to their bushy hairstyles.
For decades, Jackie Chan has dominated the global
box office with his martial arts-based action
movies. In 2001, Chan produced and starred in the
action comedy The Accidental Spy. And nowhere does
Chan's signature style present more than in
a lengthy fight scene in which his character,
Buck Yuen, an exercise gear salesman
turned criminal organization target,
fights off one bad guy after another while
completely nude. It's comical how Chan,
as Yuen, attempts to keep himself covered with
whatever random objects are at hand. Pinpoint
precise cinematography also helps keep the
nudity PG-13. But the sequence isn't perfect.
"Accidents do happen."
Here and there, Chan gives the audience a little
bit more of himself than intended. In other words,
in one way or another, The Accidental Spy
accidentally exposes almost all of Jackie Chan.
Dirty Dancing was a massive hit in 1987.
Viewers of all ages were charmed by the
story of a summer romance between
17-year-old Frances "Baby" Houseman,
played by Jennifer Grey,
and dance instructor Johnny,
played by Patrick Swayze. Dirty Dancing reminded
older audiences of the good old days when they
took summer vacations at Catskills resorts
and sex talk was for science class, if that.
While keeping things as expressly
early '60s as possible, Dirty Dancing
filmmakers made a major misstep when it
came to Baby's wardrobe. She spends most
of the summer in a pair of very short
denim shorts. Not only would those be
considered risqué according to early 1960s
standards, but they didn't even exist. Denim
shorts like Baby's didn't go mainstream
until the much more libertine '70s,
when they were popularized by – and named after –
Daisy Duke, a character on The Dukes of Hazzard.
The Indiana Jones movies were conceived as
an homage to mid-century film serials by
franchise creators Steven Spielberg and George
Lucas. Fictional treasure-hunting archaeologist
Indiana Jones is the hero, and in Raiders of the
Lost Ark and Indiana Jones and the Last Crusade,
Nazis are the bad guys. Last Crusade is set in
1938, and Indy encounters Nazis at a book burning.
"Nazis. I hate these guys."
The Nazis are clearly identifiable by their
uniforms, which are all real. They were sourced in
Eastern Europe by the film's co-costume designer
Joanna Johnston. But they aren't completely
faithful to 1938. All the actors portraying Nazis
wear uniforms loaded with medals awarded for tasks
and acts of war committed during World War II.
The thing is, that war took place largely in
the 1940s. So those medals, and the battles in
which they'd be won, wouldn't have happened yet.
Braveheart is the true-life
story of William Wallace,
a 13th-century Scottish folk hero and leader
of the opposition against the more powerful
and better-equipped English forces. While
the characters and story are mostly true,
Braveheart's still a movie, and filmmakers —
including Mel Gibson, recipient of the Best
Director and Best Picture Oscars for the film —
took a number of creative liberties with history.
Braveheart deals with Scottish identity, and,
unfortunately, many of the film's inaccuracies
relate to just that. For example, the
most enduring images from the film are
of Gibson as the warrior Wallace heading into
battle wearing blue face paint, known as woad,
and a plaid kilt. The thing is: warriors wore woad
about 1,000 years before Braveheart takes place,
and real Scots didn't wear the type of tartan
that Gibson's Wallace wears until 500 years later.
Today, thoroughbred horse
racing is a specialty sport,
but in the early to mid-1900s, it was
enormously popular. It takes a big-budget,
high-profile Hollywood movie like the
2003 Seabiscuit to restore fame and
interest to the forgotten athletes, horses
and riders, of the period. Seabiscuit was an
unlikely champion who became a big winner and
crowd favorite during the Great Depression.
Tobey Maguire played Seabiscuit's primary
jockey, John "Red" Pollard. In the film's many
racing scenes, he's seen wearing a racing helmet
with a prominent chin strap. But in the 1930s,
jockeys' helmets didn't have chin straps.
Those weren't introduced into horse racing
until the 1950s, about 20 years after
the events depicted in Seabiscuit.
Miloš Forman's film adaptation of Peter Shaffer's
play Amadeus tells the story of the last days of
famous composer Wolfgang Amadeus Mozart,
and the hatred and envy felt by his rival,
Antonio Salieri. In 1985, Amadeus won eight
Academy Awards, including Best Picture,
Best Director, Best Actor, and Best Costume
Design. The head of wardrobe, Theodor Pistek,
brought the lush, elaborate world of
late 1700s high society Vienna to life,
outfitting the actors in exquisite
wigs, waistcoats, lace, frills,
and petticoats. But Pistek put zippers on the
costumes. In a scene depicting the ballet in
Mozart's opera The Marriage of Figaro, telltale
metal teeth can be seen on the dancers' outfits.
"I don't understand. Is it modern?"
Zippers didn't exist in 18th century Austria. The
modern zipper wasn't a thing
until about 100 years later.
La La Land both does and doesn't capture the vibe
of life in modern-day Los Angeles. For example,
there are surprisingly few spontaneous
but expertly choreographed musical numbers
on the freeway despite the countless
hours Angelenos spend stuck in traffic.
At one point, Sebastian, the character
played by Ryan Gosling, and Mia,
played by Emma Stone, have a road
rage encounter. During this sequence,
jazz pianist Sebastian wears an appropriately
retro brown shirt. But in the next scene,
he arrives at his apartment to see his
sister, Laura wearing a blue shirt,
despite not having had the opportunity or time
to change. After Laura takes off, Sebastian sits
down at the piano, and he's once again dressed
in that brown shirt. It's not a magical shirt,
nor were scenes of Sebastian furiously switching
shirts cut out. It's a continuity error, which La
La Land director Damien Chazelle acknowledges in
a commentary track on the DVD version of the film.
On the whole, Captain America: The First Avenger
is a solid piece of entertainment. It elevated
star Chris Evans to superstardom, spawned two
sequels, and is one of the best-loved Marvel
movies in history. What we're saying is: It's hard
to pick this movie apart. But in the midst of all
the "pulpy action" and "pleasantly retro vibe"
the critics applaud in Captain America, there's an
historical slip-up we can hardly believe made it
into the film. About an hour and a half in, during
the train raid scene, Kenneth Choi's Jim Morita
is shown wearing a high-tech earpiece — what looks
to be a Bowman Communication military headset
— which definitely didn't exist during WWII.